[Music]
hey welcome to fat man I'm Kevin Smith I
had to find mine as well um thank you
for waiting we are starting the show
here at the scum and villainy canteen on
Hollywood Boulevard here in Hollywood
California put your hands together so
the folks know you're real at home as I
look at my make pretend watch we are
starting the show about 45 minutes late
and I only have myself to blame I will
try to blame mark barnard at quarter
after 8:00 mark barnard in text me and
says are you coming and I was like holy
[ __ ] I was like I forgot man holy [ __ ]
cuz I was watching [ __ ] acquit ik on
iTunes and [ __ ] like that it's just not
that great of an excuse but I know it
which is weird cuz i knew the ending
already too so like I was still Dovan
and then he told me he was like we're
doing a [ __ ] show idiot no [ __ ] so I
got dressed and [ __ ] came over sacked
out eating pita and hummus bread and
[ __ ] like an Israeli [ __ ] and
still got dressed so [ __ ] quick it
got over yourself and it's my fault
because I just should have texted you
earlier that's it yeah it's your
responsibility to get me here on time so
as a way of saying sorry everyone that
leaves JC or Andrew somebody will hand
you a signed eight-by-ten of key ass
that's see this is a now I feel like Ted
Kennedy I did something bad and people
like good boy don't reward that [ __ ] be
like next time get on time [ __ ] thank
you I try he didn't that's the fucked-up
thing you're watching that movie it's
like two hours they're like dude make
the call
make the call I mean spoilers make the
call and [ __ ] he don't make the call so
me bringing autographed eight-by-tens is
me making the call this analogy fell
apart a while ago it's a point of
interest who's calling go ahead who is
he calling he's got to call the
authorities to tell them that he flipped
his car and there's a wormhole to lady
drowning yeah who when you watch the
movie and you know if you read history
but that's [ __ ] boring but if you
watched the movie she was alive for a
long [ __ ] time like he could have got
her out if he just would have called
anybody that his diver at one point he's
like somebody had called me I could have
got her out in 25 minutes and you're
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man then we land
on the moon and everyone forgets about
it for like two minutes but then people
I hate and Ted Kennedy kills somebody
and then that's where the real movie
kicks in and [ __ ] spoilers so so I was
knee-deep in that [ __ ] but it's not
nearly as fun as coming here this is one
my favorite things in the world to do so
I'm glad that you texted me I just wish
you texted me a little earlier I brought
eight-by-ten sign for everybody what did
you bring mark I brought Kevin Smith yes
good boy oh my god excellent point
without mark you would have just that
mark tonight
what have you been up to tell me about
your weaknesses and normally when we do
this we've already filled each other in
in the back alley which sounds
completely homoerotic that's where our
green room is in the back alley well
we've already filled each other in but
this time I'm literally like I have no
idea what did you well that my own and
dry hit me but I've been I've been
working on this television show I saw I
saw a lovely little Instagram I know
it's a different TV show but I saw an
Instagram of you you put up a billboard
for Castle Rock yes spotted in the wild
I like the I like I like the image yeah
the image is cool if you see the up and
down poster on it yeah
it's purposely designed to look like an
old like signet paperback cover right
you know like an old Stephen King book
though like that it's got the same
[ __ ] font in the whole thing yeah oh
my god it looks like nice burner Salem's
Lot t-shirt it does kind of look like
that
yeah haunting image like as yes whoever
market hats off cuz right away I was
like that's [ __ ] intriguing the hulu
team is killing it is that the opening
episode or is that just a image it is
just there there is a moment where
somebody jumps off a roof but it that
that is not a specific thing right it's
just kind of haunting and evocative but
yeah it was it was super [ __ ] weird
to be driving down kohanga like oh [ __ ]
there's a TV show that I did and that
day that I saw it was this seventh
anniversary thanks to timehop of when i
first encountered an alphas poster in
the wild which was the first show that I
worked on so 7 years to the day I saw
the poster for a show that I did in the
real world twice twice so 7 years from
now you'll get another job I mean
that's the trend you guys that's an
awesome feeling man I don't really work
on [ __ ] that ever gets put on
Billboard's or bus stop ads or something
like that but a few times it had happen
I was at home I got because we're kids
who grew up in the outdoor age of
advertising now people get their
advertisements like right on their phone
or when they're looking at [ __ ]
Facebook or whatever the [ __ ]
but for us back in the day if you were
on a billboard you were [ __ ] famous
it was huge and [ __ ] and that never goes
away still to this day when I Drive
around Los Angeles I'm always doing this
[ __ ] like [ __ ] the dude in Goodfellas
looking for a helicopter but I'm just
always just trying to see the billboard
so much so my wife said keep your eye on
the road I'm like [ __ ] you I moved to LA
for the billboards I don't know why I
was jealous of my left she's in another
car apparently but right but uh yeah
billboards man or a big [ __ ] deal
especially being like a New York kid
like going into Manhattan going into
Times Square and see and like larger
than life there's [ __ ] Schwarzenegger
astride the world like a colossus the
giant Batman symbol that was in Times
Square in 1989 like leading up to the
release of the first Batman yes LA is
good for that because there's a lot of
egos that need stroking and so those are
ultimately the only reason there are
billboards anywhere in Los Angeles just
so that executive or that director that
writer can drive as my [ __ ] movie
you're not [ __ ] wrong dude I was at
Disney this week and for [ __ ] four
blocks around Disney you can't [ __ ]
not run into an ant-man and the wasp
poster and I'm like they well they must
feel very good about this like they've
sold tickets to themselves
it's although I will say that [ __ ]
movie looks phenomenal the trailer looks
palomo the reviews so far been great and
I saw Peyton Reed said something in the
press today which I was like oh [ __ ]
like it wasn't like who does this
gossipy but it is kind of inside
baseball and it made me go like it
reminded me of what happened when I saw
Civil War he talked about how he did
ant-man and then in Civil War they did
spoilers giant man and he was thinking
that he was going to get to do that in
the sequel that man but they did it in
civil war first and you can't what he's
supposed to say like you can't [ __ ]
do that they're like there are toys
[ __ ]
you know we do whatever we want so they
did giant man in Civil War before he
could do giant men in the ant-man sequel
and then they were gonna introduce the
wasp in Civil War as well and apparently
that's when he dug in and he was like no
you can't lie give me some yeah just
give her her own movie don't like debut
her and [ __ ] him four shots in the
middle of Civil War they already got a
bunch of heroes man like leave it for
this so he won that battle and not a
battle like where he had [ __ ] on the
ropes and they were bleeding I have to
be very careful of my terminology cuz
everything we [ __ ] say is being
listened to and written about online
[ __ ] and always turned into something I
didn't say like we were talking about
[ __ ] somebody has to question about
the Dark Knight trilogy and and
Christian Bale playing [ __ ] Batman
and I was like ah [ __ ] that would have
been cool and I went out of my way to be
like hey man this ain't [ __ ] on
Affleck this has everything to do with
the idea of carrying over continuity
that's it blah blah blah and every
article was Smith shits and Affleck's
mouth again so I guess I gotta be
careful what I said but [ __ ] that movie
looks [ __ ] astounding yeah I'm on
board I'm on board and maybe if they
didn't have spider-man they would have
introduced the wasp there but you know
they gave us enough believe me but it's
interesting that that something like
that could happen like when you see the
trailers for ant-man and the wasps
there's they use him as giant man quite
a bit and stuff and it was a fantastic
like well did they even use that to
salsa before I don't think so that was
that was like their big secret right
that he becomes giant me yeah they
released it in a Lego toy picture and
that's how most people found out but
never put it in any spots or anything
like that until like the week before I
think and then they were like alright
it's totally I'm as smart putting that
foot forward as [ __ ] when we had when we
were Marcus II I like to think of myself
as a smart marketer but I'm not at all
when we had tusks I was like you can't
show the walrus in the [ __ ] trailer
and that would have made people maybe go
you know if they
if they were like holy [ __ ] that looks
fog does that a [ __ ] walrus guys yeah
here's mice 12 bucks you live and learn
and she like that so in any event okay I
saw the poster yes there you go for the
TV show I worked on I'm working on this
new show called Treadstone so I've been
in in the room on that the most oh thank
you thank you
though the weirdest part of my week was
like is because the Treadstone room is
not very far from here it's on like
Cahuenga
the long prayer or whatever it is and
and so we're gonna take a walk as we do
like twice a day we're like well get out
what [ __ ] weed sitting in this room
is that what people do in the writers
room they go out for healthy constitutes
go for low yeah stretch our legs we've
been sitting there thinking for too long
and so we're all about to go go out for
our walk for our daily walkies and one
of my core is like is that Kevin Smith
waving at you in the parking lot and I
turn around and he's just like eating
nachos out of his car just waving at me
I was I was a car a lot leaning in the
car like [ __ ] Ferris Bueller man and
I was like do you have a kiss for daddy
I was at we were doing a remix there
listen watching a playback of something
we were working on and as I was sitting
in the car eatin [ __ ] vegan nachos
waiting for other people to show up I
looked in the rearview and I was like
goddamn that looks like mark and I got
out and it was mark and a bunch of dudes
looking at a car like a Porsche or some
such [ __ ] and that's why I still didn't
think it was you because I was like this
guy for years he's never once been like
oh I [ __ ] have a 350 big-block in my
car man like he's never shown an
interest in a car and here he is [ __ ]
studying this [ __ ] so I just kept
sitting there eating my nachos and
watching and waiting for you to [ __ ]
look over it and everyone else looked
over but you which made me think he
really is a car guy like and then
finally one of them was like I think
your friend is stalking you and Mark
looked over knows what so what it that's
where you guys do all the writing yeah
we're talking are you blue skying or
actually right we're we're not writing
yet we won't be writing for other month
or so so now it's like the deep
conversation of what's gonna happen next
mmm for eighteen different characters
all over the world because it's a
[ __ ] international spy show so where
should we go this week Jakarta fine how
about Duchamp Bay is that real
I don't know so I'm spies like this it's
a spy show [ __ ] we're going the road
to Duchamp Bay is on the table till like
don't matter we're shooting it in
Burbank anyway
that's pretty except the greatest thing
that I learned this week though is
because we have lots of conversations
about like this [ __ ] international
crime deals and syndicates and smuggling
and whatever and it's always a question
of like how much is too much like how
much money on the table feels like too
much money and how much feels cartoonish
okay and then somebody told us to hurry
of and this is for real and if you
google Don Johnson and eight billion
dollars you will get this story which is
Don Johnson when he was on Nash Bridges
where as traveling overseas who's in
Germany and he gets pulled over by the
police in Germany I guess for speeding
in Germany and he was he had eight
billion dollars in bearer bonds in his
trunk are you [ __ ] serious swear to
God
dollars this isn't an episode of Miami
Vice
like I'm sure that's where like the
[ __ ] Interpol table are you Sonny
Crockett didn't get [ __ ] Sonny
Crockett in why was what what his excuse
was I was making a film industry
purchase what was he buying a studio he
could have all of the studios that are
in the Nash Bridges like I bought all of
film today we're eight billion dollar
did anybody investigate this further it
just it vanished off the face
it's got like it got buried if they're
still like if you this is more
interesting than Jeff a quintic man like
what is Don Johnson doing in Germany
with eight billion dollars he's the
question of our time and like Horne Lee
why aren't we good friends with Don Jose
[Laughter]
got a lot of [ __ ] money man
at some point eight billion dollars in
Hans Gruber's Barry Bonds and the trunk
in his [ __ ] Porsche they were like
come on man Don Johnson what are you
some kind of common thief he's like I'm
an exceptional piece
oops - alan rickman alright so I had a
well I mean it wasn't a bad week at all
but I had a we announced this week sad
news for some I had taken it a lot
earlier so like by the time we announced
it I it was old news to me the good
folks at AMC who've been our lovely home
for the last seven seasons and 96
episodes on Conan book men brought us
into a room and they were like you're
too old and shot us in the head they
cancelled our show they were not shitty
about it at all they were very [ __ ]
sweet the head of the network called
Charlie Collier very nice guy and he was
like this hurts this one hurts I never I
was hoping I'd never have to make this
call I was a column and don't worry
about it honestly I was expecting this
call after season [ __ ] one so the
fact that we made it to 96 episodes like
the trust me you never have to [ __ ]
apologize for that or anything like that
so yeah came to a close all good things
come to an end and again I was like
every season when they called to say
we're going again I was always like
really surprised and and like Jesus
really like wow thanks and [ __ ] but this
season was the first season that like I
was like oh we're definitely getting
renewed I just had a [ __ ] heart
attack like
there's no way they'd cut me loose after
a health crisis and they were like
goodbye goodbye to the real walking dead
and off I went and stuff like that you
made the mistake of believing that I
know just what I only believe I felt
safe I was like oh we're safe as kittens
but again it was I I got it's a true
[ __ ] Mitzvah on that network's behalf
that I got to make as many of those
shows as we did like it's literally at
the end of the day it's a show about my
friends like it's a show about some
people that I always liked and stuff
like that and the fact that we wound up
with the TV show that I could be on this
side of the country and you know watch a
version of my friends on TV like and not
just on TV but like we were on [ __ ]
AMC when it was like AMC when [ __ ]
they were like knock it out the park
with all the your premiere seasons of
The Walking Dead and [ __ ] we were on
the heels of Mad Men that's where we got
our show comic book men they just wanted
something to match up with Matt but we
were there it's true that was a true
story we were there for like a really
good time in my career when I was a guy
and making movies anymore go [ __ ]
yourself and everybody was like he's
imploding he's [ __ ] dead in this
business and then all sudden I had a
show on the number one network the
most-watched network so it was a
wonderful thing to have when we had it
and stuff sad to see it end but not like
sad like you know [ __ ] write your
Congressman what an injustice like not
at all we were on Netflix shape so I see
that all the time there's people online
going like save comic book men and I was
like you know we're out there in the
world pitching it because we got a whole
[ __ ] library that never really went
anywhere other than AMC that somebody
could buy turnkey library and if they
wanted to make more you know we're all
still up for that as well so it could
still like find a home and stuff but at
the end of the day like very sweet of
people of like you know tweet like we
got to stop this and put your efforts
into other things we're parent losing a
Supreme Court justice tweet about that
it seems far more important than this
stuff but it was such a great [ __ ]
run I I thank everybody not just here
but at home listening and or watching
that ever tuned in for that show what a
dream come true I didn't it was
dream come true I never dreamed I'd have
a [ __ ] TV show about my friends and
me and my friends my world they did
those little montage of between scenes
and it would always be like shots of
like [ __ ] I like movies I made and
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's hanging in the story
the whole thing was just so cool and so
is sad to see them and stuff and maybe
it continues in the future but as it
stands right now the version that we did
on antsy we gave it a Viking funeral
that's passed on and stuff so it was
it's it ended nicely like you know
ultimately it's a breakup right we broke
up and whenever you hear like people go
like oh we had a good breakup or fringe
like bull yeah one of you ain't friends
you know this this was kind of the kind
of that like at the end of the day you
know they took it as far as they could
and stuff and we took the ride and our
shows fortunes were always tied in with
the Walking Dead as The Walking Dead the
audience went so when our very late
night audience and stuff so I'll miss it
but honestly it wasn't as big a part of
my life as it was the boys they'd shoot
for three four months every summer it
was like their summer job and I'd pop in
three times during the shooting to
record the wrap arounds of the podcast
so the cast which is of course the boys
and the crew were real tight they'd all
moved down from New York and go live
down in the area all summer long and
whatnot they were a real family so I
feel bad for all those folks who you
know they got regular jobs in other
places and stuff but this was kind of a
special thing they put together
something warm and wonderful it's weird
because I didn't put it together myself
I've said many times all I said was hey
why don't we do Pawn Stars in a comic
book store and the folks at original
media which became truly original we're
smarter enough to do something better
than that they created a show that was
essentially clerks the unscripted show
for some I saw the episode that was like
only [ __ ] there's like Clarence man they
work for a living and they're Clark's
and [ __ ] and they're like you didn't
realize we were doing that
I said no I was just saying Pawn Stars
the car learned it from you
yes so it was it was a great experience
but yeah it came to an end
I don't be sad that it ended be happy
that it happened at all oh [ __ ] yeah
that's how I feel about the whole thing
you're doing the [ __ ] volt on though
right we are doing vulgar fun yeah I
announced for my birthday tickets go on
sale I guess on Friday back in New
Jersey we're gonna do a vulgar thon it's
a film festival that we started back in
like 1998 where we just show the movies
that like I've been involved with so
this year is the 20th anniversary of
that and so I was like I'm turned 48 and
I [ __ ] lived through the heart attack
and [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'm gonna throw a
vulgar athon so on August 2nd back in
New Jersey in Red Bank the cradle of
[ __ ] civilization we will be kicking
back and watching some classic movies
recording some [ __ ] podcast you're
gonna be on that side of the country I
can be on the day of my birth to honor
the newborn King you know it's entirely
possible let me on a plane as Chen you
know people from back I got a family
back yeah so you can kill many birds
with one stone we should talk about that
maybe you do come back and stuff alright
so what else going on anything I got
nothing else in the real world although
I did watch Japan of 12 episodes of Luke
Cage oh [ __ ] you want deeper right I
went deep already and I think it is as a
whole a better season than the first
season was okay
it doesn't quite like and the first
season is a weird one because it's so
bifurcated by you know you have I know
who the villain is I don't know who the
villain is oh [ __ ] the dude who just won
an Oscar is amazing and then he dies
spoilers and then this other guy who's
fine but isn't that guy you know so the
first season is really like Pekin and
valley whereas this is way smoother all
across the board and bushmaster is an
amazing villain alright and Boosh masta
and and it's also it is so like having
grown up in an immigrant family having
grown up in a Caribbean family so much
of that feels so culturally resonant for
me and there's a scene where where
we're misty night is going to talk to
this woman who's you know some had just
died or whatever and this woman lives in
a house and all the couches are wrapped
in plastic
like my grandmother like all stirred in
plastic it's like there was a post tree
and then a plastic cover so your stinky
ass wouldn't [ __ ] up a really nice couch
because it's the one really nice couch
she ever had so do not put your damn
pass on my couch auntie it's a I'll do
you think I'm talking to friends like
y'all my Jewish grandmother did that my
Cuban grandmother did that it was a we
made it to the new world we bought some
nice [ __ ] and don't you dare your
punk-ass [ __ ] it up
now you must have come from a rich
family because my grandma couldn't
afford a plastic cover for our couch we
looked up to those upholstered people be
like what's it like up there rich man
why's your house so shiny so if fat you
felt it I felt the feels and any user
Bionic bionic arm mr. Knight oh hell
yeah
but what episodes that come in really
there's a great bar fight it's her it's
her and calling wing where she doesn't
have the arm right and so it's it's
daughters of the dragon but misty luck
once they gotten punched me in the face
and she does they're like stitch over
the jab and then follow through with the
right and she doesn't have an arm and
said she just whiffed sit and the entire
fight is her learning to come to grips
with the fact that she can't come to
grips with that side of her body anymore
and it's kind of beautiful it's kind of
great like it is so much about the like
learning to adjust to your new reality
right and and and then when she gets the
bionic arm and then it's the weird like
oh [ __ ] this thing is here and I'm she's
not quite crunching hugs and a half but
she can't open drawers the way she used
to like her finger doesn't fit in the
trigger the way it used to is it's a lot
of like really really smart like that's
what that storyline is about not
learning to to kind of get accustomed to
your new reality how many episodes if
you're on episode 10 there's three more
eleven twelve thirteen they're still
doing those chunky seasons yeah that is
still a problem I mean not like the
greatest problem in the world but all of
these seasons would be benefited by be
only ten if they were like defenders
short yeah I mean even eight but yeah
1010 is a sweet spot but alfre woodard
as Mariah who you actually get to hear
her call herself black Mariah which is
kind of great
Oh get at it yeah but it's also really
like kind of haunting tragic reason why
she calls herself black Mariah which is
great but watching her descend into
madness is kind of lovely because it's a
free [ __ ] woodard who's like an
amazing actress yeah to begin with and
always has been and suddenly she's doing
like material that you never imagined
she and the tenth episode is the were
reintroducing iron fist episode which I
was a little trepidatious because you
know my feelings about iron fist I will
be I was happy to report that a he just
[ __ ] iron fist like a [ __ ]
like everybody gets the iron fist like
he's no longer like I can't but they
find a way to actually do the Danny is
helping Luke find his Center and Luke is
helping Danny not be so much of a
[ __ ] entitled prick they're building
them on a shirt real and I have this big
fight scene in the warehouse which is
great which ends exactly the way you
hoped it would which is and I don't
remember this in the books he's only not
a deep power minute refrigerator but
they do a patty cake thing was that part
of the book anybody ever seen this it is
it is their version of this it's a
little bit of like the fastball a
special or or the moment in the Avengers
when Iron Man uses cap shield as like
aid [ __ ] [ __ ] it's pretty [ __ ]
awesome I'm like I can't believe I just
smiled the smile of coolness at a moment
featuring Iron Fist yeah which I praise
put that on the post which I did not do
for 21 previous episodes from our
artists in it like you guys somebody
earned their [ __ ] paycheck that
sounds like whoever did well who did
this is cheo cheo Coker did the whole
season
so it sounds like somebody who maybe
watched those shows where maybe at least
listen to the audience and was like well
how do we improve this care we gotta fix
this we're gonna be saddled with doing
the both of these together in the future
we gotta make this right and it sounds
like so far so good so far so good and I
think next week knock on wood we might
have Jo Coker as a guest on this your
podcast Oh get out of here bringing the
quality guests we might have we might
have him in the house that beats my
signed eight-by-tens well done that'd be
cool doc well cool on one level bad on
now I gotta watch all [ __ ] 13
episodes before next week that's a lot
of work the other thing we get to talk
to him about is he wrote Creed - what
yeah really
about that [ __ ] trailer oh my god
like I thought it here I'll be honest
with you like this is this is good
marketing you know we movie marketing is
such that like you'll be like that
sounds [ __ ] dumb when they go into
production and then you'll see a trailer
and be like oh my god I love this more
than my firstborn an only child I'm
waiting I can't wait six months to see
that and you countdown then you get into
the movie theater you're like one please
you get inside it like [ __ ] tricked
again so generally speaking this could
be one of those cases but I did not have
much high hopes for this movie not like
I thought it would be [ __ ] but I loved
Creed Creed was a comic book movie so
much so the Ryan Coogler made Creed up
made an even better come becomes a yeah
and again black panther a shield this
this was a phenomenal flick that made me
give a [ __ ] about the rocky world once
again I didn't know I had any love left
but I was a girl [ __ ] we could here we
go again [ __ ] and so I bought
into us I liked the trailer when I saw
the movie I felt deeply in love and [ __ ]
you know it has that Field of Dreams dad
thing going for it in this case it's
like a dad a kid never news like when he
was spoilers he gets knocked down to the
canvas and sees everybody who could
possibly [ __ ] inspire him to get up
is the image of his [ __ ] father that
makes it go pee and he [ __ ] gets up
if that ain't some comic book [ __ ] I
don't know what is that
such a beautiful moment then it's
biblical to which is also a comic book
so first one I ever read so pictures
I loved Creed and and then when they
said hey [ __ ] Sylvester Stallone's
like you'll all do it and then he was
taking over a Creed you know on one
level you're like well they're his
characters so of course he should be
able to do what he wants but on the
other hand you're like you're gonna be
missing that crucial element the magic
of Ryan Coogler that was made by a fan
him and his friend were fans they [ __ ]
imagine if you made a Creed movie and
one day aggregated into making a Creed
movie it was made with all passion all
fire all love same thing that rocky was
made with when Stallone was hungry and
[ __ ] like that maybe rocky - probably
even rocky 3 to a large degree maybe
even rocky for rodney 5 he stopped
[ __ ] crying so he had other [ __ ] to
do regardless but I mean this this Creed
movie was [ __ ] wonderful so when they
said Sylvester Stallone is doing Creed -
I was like oh man this sounds like a
[ __ ] cash grab and I'm sure I bump
into it online and watch it eventually
but I was not probably gonna go see it
in the theater and then they rolled the
[ __ ] trailer last week and I watched
the trailer and I'm like yeah man it
just looks like more the same why are
they pretending this is a big deal we
saw [ __ ] the fight of his life it
happened as [ __ ] and he got the girl
[ __ ] this story what could possibly why
are they saying it's just like his dad
and why is he telling him he dad died in
his arms and he won't stand for that
again and why are they and then I was in
the last [ __ ] shot of the trailer is
the guy he's gonna fight getting into
the ring and he turns around the baggers
robe says Drago and I was like oh
[Laughter]
that was so smart I didn't give a [ __ ]
about this movie till I was a continuity
I know who Drago is I felt like my mom
when she could connect Marvel movies you
know like just like oh he was an Iron
Man I'm like well done mom well done
oh it was so [ __ ] good you see the
trailer oh yeah like nine times oh no
Kim pretty gram good like I you got to
give it to him after I watched the
trailer I was like I forgot services
Salaam and make a movie since I was like
crapping my pants and [ __ ] so he is very
good at playing and audience oh he knows
it and that marketing campaign whoever
said and I don't know this hammer
somebody MGM whoever the [ __ ] cut it
that said just hold it until the last
possible second and then pull the giant
Russian dick out deserves all the money
in the world they won the internet that
day was [ __ ] astounding have you ever
seen there's a I think MGM cut it maybe
as promotion for four rocky box it or
something but MGM cut a fake 30 for 30
you know the ESPN 30 for their
documentaries about the the glass no
spite when they treated like rocky
defeating Ivan Drago as an actual
historical event and so like talking to
Russians like I didn't care that much
about the fight but then I see this
looking about Boeing it's aa bene strong
strong like bull
but he gives me the opportunity and it's
literally talk to like some old Russian
[Music]
and then they go talk to the American
guys in like the White House was like
yeah you know we had a really hard time
you know Reagan wanted nothing to do
with glass nose but any [ __ ] saw
rocky Balboa's they're not there's like
you know a lot
maybe we can and it's like 15 minutes of
playing it totally straight that this
fight existed and changed the world
ladies and gentlemen marks one man
thirty four thirty I did not hear a word
after your Russian impression I mean
because I was like that's [ __ ] good
bad
I do way better Russian than I do
British rich abundant proof that I
cannot do a British accent the Russian
we can get to those cos Boris badenov
good man
good enough for bad enough yeah man that
[ __ ] trailer absolute [ __ ] magic
I'm in I'm in like and you know they got
Dolph Lundgren back to train the young
Drago did I not tell you that pardon me
I'm having my second heart attack of the
year are you [ __ ] me they didn't
even hit that I mean God why didn't I
think of that of course they would but
they don't doing anything he's like you
didn't think they'd bring me back for
this one
like but they don't show him in the
trailer nope so smart because if they
had I would have been like oh I smell
this Covenants ya know wow man well
that's the only way you could have
improved that releve showed that robe
and then they cut to him and he's like
I'm bad credit wow that's awesome
I'm going to kill another Creed oh
that's [ __ ] dope man Wow so in the
story he's training his son out of kill
because he killed an American leg he
killed a Creed like I'm going to kill
another Creed
that is so [ __ ] fantastic I mean I'm
glad it's fake but it's so [ __ ] like
fantastic it's so like that's less like
Shakespearean to some degree man looking
[ __ ] what 70 [ __ ] hundred yeah and
he's still pulling like magic cards out
of his ass good for him I'm gonna leave
the steroids alone alright alright so I
guess we're done talking about all that
you yes shall we start the show probably
could shoot off the show prob with this
show ladies gentlemen into two parts and
the first part is where we cover all the
news man and then when we do that
there's only one person that goes deep
dive and dumpster diving if you will for
the news and that's Mark Martin give it
up for Mark II looked at the Internet
what is happening in the world of geek
my friend I am like I'm like the warlock
of deadline you are all deep cuts right
yeah you remember they were making an
Indiana Jones 5 yes yeah yeah Lucas was
like one more time yeah one more time
and Spielberg was like god dammit do you
remember the last time come on Chris
okay
because Harrison Ford is going to start
an Indiana Jones 5 yeah they've been
talking about this movie now for four
years I think it was announced in 2014
yes it's got a release date of 2020 and
it's been delayed again because the
script isn't right again like a sharpie
anybody goes sharpie I got one silver
sharpie I can't work like that black
sharpie anybody that's red thank you
but I'll do use that later but if you
got black one thank you go ahead
and so they brought in the the
wunderkind who worked wonders on solo
Lawrence Kasdan's kid who not okay
Jonathan casdim to rewrite Indiana Jones
five so they're bringing him to well
they're the problem with solo wasn't the
script were scripts I don't know I mean
there's two different versions of movie
we only saw one but apparently only one
of them had a script right that was kind
of their big beef was later I'd live in
a lot of this bacon is up we can make up
a Star Wars movie on the fly I'll leave
that right there but but yeah man it is
that it's like I liked so low I thought
so low it was fine and it was good
fanservice too like if that look if that
like here's a kid who grew up around
this [ __ ] we were all like fans have
been whatnot and I'm sure everyone in
this room thinks they could probably
write a pretty good version of an
Indiana Jones movie and said we
certainly know how not to write a bad
one just don't do Crystal Skull and
you're off to the races instead but this
guy was close to the source you sitting
those dad's [ __ ] me most of his life
or whatever Vianney is passing it's got
to be right there so if they're gonna
pick somebody to take a run at Indiana
Jones take we let it be him my hope is
that they delay it long enough so that
it's impossible for Harrison Ford to
come back because I just I don't want 80
year old Harris looking like a true fan
man you're like I love Harris's hood so
much I don't want him to be in this
movie
I don't want him to hurt himself because
he would absolutely hurt himself you
would he broke like eight things on
force awakens right I know but you can't
kill him this guy like downed an
airplane and got out he's there I'm
alright
you know I got this hold my beer we
crash another one I don't know I say
give him one more shot at it for [ __ ]
sake like you know if he's still here
and stuff especially because the last
one around you know was I mean with all
due respect there's some good stuff but
like crystal skull was was not the way I
wanted to see Indiana Jones and his
cinematic career and stuff like this so
hopefully they'll be like one one more
round of it but you don't give a f--- I
just I I can ask you this if he stopped
or do you think that character should or
kid could keep going could definitely
absence should absolutely yeah I think I
always sort of believed that the the key
to a character's immortality is
interpretation is is translation is that
you know Captain Kirk doesn't get to be
an immortal character unless somebody
else gets to interpret that there's been
a thousand Robin Hood's there's been at
least more than two Darth Vader's like
the ones we remember forever are because
we've seen different versions of it and
we get to choose we get to imprint on
the ones we saw as kids and your kids
get to imprint on the ones that are
theirs and it's a generational thing and
if a great character there's gonna be a
king Arthur no reason why this guy
couldn't be as big a pop cultural figure
as King Arthur you need him to be able
to be replayed over and over again for
every generation that goes forward the
smartest [ __ ] it never occurred to me
that like yeah like you know [ __ ]
Robin Hood and King Arthur these stories
been around for so long
there's classics of [ __ ] literature
and stuff like that so you don't even
think about your characters but like
some of these characters are strong
enough like I mean the namesake of the
show we rarely talk about him anymore
but Batman himself is a character that's
only been around for what 75 years at
this point maybe 70 years or something
like that and
one hundred two hundred years from now
they'll still be telling stories about
absolutely [ __ ] Wayne so I guess
you're right I guess Indiana Jones could
just [ __ ] no reason legendary Lake Flash
Gordon is could you imagine like one day
some kid is like oh another [ __ ]
Batman movie I mean I know some critics
are like that now but I mean but it
could you imagine like just being like
uh like how every time they make a new
Robin Hood movie a bunch of people like
this [ __ ] again but I get he's [ __ ]
bow and arrow guy but you're right it's
always in the hands of the teller like
there's always gonna be a bond and there
was always going to be who's your
favorite Bond because you get to choose
and I think that that's important to
longevity and I think that at some point
there's going to have to be because
they're never going to stop making these
movies like pass the mantle like here's
a new guy here's Chris Pratt here's
Nathan Fillion here's some super [ __ ]
handsome Dems worth we haven't met yet
this is a [ __ ] creature that we cut
together we change sliced from the DNA
of to Chris's Hemsworth and Pratt
he is hems worthy we had poly just juice
in a jar there we go
yeah man [ __ ] and it hadn't occurred to
me my characters gonna die with me that
much I know
but [ __ ] these character and not
because I want to nobody gives a [ __ ]
but it feels like these characters I
mean [ __ ] they're telling stories about
Green Hornet still and that was like a
radio character predates even [ __ ]
the the TV show yeah I guess it's
possible could you imagine writing a
character that [ __ ] lasts that long
well after your [ __ ] demise people
are still writing that story it's
bananas like Arthur Conan Doyle like
we're still telling Sherlock Holmes
stories a hundred years hence long after
that did was dead because everybody gets
to own it a little bit and again you
can't as a fan you don't get to own your
thing but you get to imprint upon your
version of it I remember reading in
chocos when I was a kid and now you
giving me this one and Jeremy Brett was
my Sherlock Holmes and - [ __ ]
Cumberbatch and everybody gets to have
it everybody gets to believe in it in
their own way do you know that Arthur
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle was a big
believer in fairies and
the world did not see return coming but
alright it's true man there are fairies
there these two little girls in England
or the [ __ ] what were they called the
Cottonwood fairs I forget with Akkad
early fairies these two little girls in
Turners century I think it was England
took a photo of these fairies in the
[ __ ] yard and like you know it this
was like maybe one of the earliest
internet scandals before there was an
Internet a bunch of people in the world
well holy [ __ ] they [ __ ] photographed
fairies and a bunch of other people were
like are you [ __ ] crazy like clearly
they're cutouts from a greeting card
that's what they look like
two-dimensional images but turn the
century or whatever it's in the old
timey days to say the least and nobody
had seen a fairy before and [ __ ] so you
know there was nobody to say it wasn't
so a bunch of people believed in it
including Sir Arthur Conan Doyle he
wasn't met with the girls Cod early
fairies that their names I forget
he wasn't met with them and stuff wrote
about the fairies and said I've seen the
pictures and this is absolutely [ __ ]
true and then one day the girls got
older and they were like no we just cut
those out we drew them and cut them out
and took pictures and Arthur Conan Doyle
was like well well I did do Sherlock
Holmes I remember that part like yeah
and I spent like 50 years as a coke
fiend so don't Leslie a cokehead no
wonder he believed in fairies he was
like yeah I believe in fairies so greed
I'm seeing him right now anyway what
else we go
Lucasfilm there was a there was a rumor
that came out I think was last week the
Lucasfilm was abandoning all hope in the
spin-offs of the Star Wars movie yeah I
believe Collider wrote that story saying
that scuttling everything things are
getting Scott old [ __ ] the word
scuttle was used quite early yeah more
schooling than I've heard since like
Huntford October the captain is
scuttling the ship that's right it did
say there's a one time I'd ever heard
the word scuttle what does it mean
exactly it means to to sink at the
bottom and destroy the [ __ ] yeah why not
just say he's sinking the [ __ ] job
like why why come up with another word
kinder word a cuter worthy it's like a
fish scuttle fish captain scuttling like
aw let's join them
no you [ __ ] hit me be sick in the
boat oh I didn't know what scuttling
meant
I thought there'd be music but yes in
the wake of solos underperformance yes
collider was reporting that Disney's
piss fair and they're changing
everything is there a new report the new
report is that they haven't abandoned
everything right but just that they are
sort of re-examining for real what's
going to happen do they want my advice I
think they do the internet would love
your advice I am let's see I would not
scuttle as much I would keep going with
these standalone Star Wars movies number
one you got yourself a big fat expensive
IPE got to pay off over years and
they've done a lot of it with those saga
movies with force awakens and with last
Jedi well you got to keep going then and
buy this [ __ ] to put it on a shelf so
you got to keep making more movies and
stuff so you make solo and it doesn't
work well kick back and look at that
thing why well you made two versions of
the movie so that's probably not a good
thing but number two you took a
character that we all know he's human
being
God had played him still alive yeah and
they killed him in the other movie and
[ __ ] but you could have told the solo
story about him like two minutes before
he got killed how about you tell the
story what a kid grows up but he's like
[ __ ] you dad and kylo Ren takes off and
[ __ ] like that and Hans like [ __ ] this
and leaves Leia like there's you could
have made that solo movie and I'm not
saying they were stupid for not doing it
but I think if you had made a han Solo
movie with Harrison Ford as we saw with
force awakens everyone would have
[ __ ] shown up because that's who the
Han Solo is so when you make a han Solo
movie and you're like this kids Han Solo
now you know the core audience is like
well I don't know maybe yeah I don't
think so what I would have done and what
they should keep doing is making these
standalone moves and again [ __ ] I gotta
say this for the Internet
I love that I've loved that movie and I
don't think it was a bad idea that they
made that movie
please let that be the headline but that
being said like you know what you know
what is a homerun idea a boba fett movie
one of the one of the reasons why is
because it's a [ __ ] outfit you know
what I'm saying like nobody's sitting
there going he better look like he
looked like in that one [ __ ] prequel
man like they just want to see the
outfit doing cool [ __ ] things him
being a badass throw an ig-88 for a
[ __ ] scene or two and [ __ ] like that
there's so many things you could do
because he's ageless that [ __ ] suits
ageless you'll never be like we got to
get somebody else to wear the suit you
can but it won't matter because you
don't [ __ ] know who's under and [ __ ]
if you want to go nuts
[ __ ] hire somebody to play Boba Fett
with her like you know what man who's
the most [ __ ] who's the most popular
movie star in the world at this point
somebody that every Chris Pratt bang
they're like guess what Boba Fett is
Chris [ __ ] Pratt and everyone's like
but wait he was some random Australian
guy and Lucas is trilogy look [ __ ] him
you know this Chris Pratt from now on
and [ __ ] it would be amazing but you
don't even have to [ __ ] do that
cuz it's a cool outfit it's like making
an action figure movie it's like looking
at [ __ ] Iron Man so definitely make
your Boba Fett movie you're not gonna
lose money you can't [ __ ] up a Boba Fett
movie make a Yoda movie you can't [ __ ]
that up he's a little puppet he's a
special effect and he'll never get older
and he'll never die just like cocoon so
you want to make a wookie movie give us
a planet of [ __ ] wookies cuz he looks
the same in every [ __ ] movie there's
so much Star Wars IP that you could [ __ ]
with that everybody be like here take my
money take my money I just think they
pick the wrong one to begin with III
don't think it was like what a [ __ ]
idiot they are for doing it but I think
in retrospect like maybe you expand the
universe or tell one of these throwback
stories the way they did with rogue one
what did we like about rogue one tied
into Star Wars and hey there's some
[ __ ] guest spots there's a cameo from
[ __ ] Princess Leia there's a cameo
from [ __ ] dr. Eva's own and [ __ ] like
that stuff like that but it told a
[ __ ] story that stood alone and it
didn't like take any characters that you
knew and loved and recast them so I just
think Solo was a tricky proposition
I also came what six months after last
Jedi hopefully what they learn from that
too is like just wait a year year to
year with a Star Wars project like you
don't have to do to an ear you'll make
people wait and anticipate it more if
you just do what they do I don't know if
they can Marvel eyes that world yet I'll
take a Marvel movie every six months
I'll be honest with you I'll take a
Marvel movie every six minutes if they'd
give it to me instead but the start but
that lends itself to that episodic
narrative because there's a zillion
[ __ ] comic books you can take source
material for and they've been telling
these stories of these characters for
eons Star Wars there's a canon of three
movies that we've all been kind of
spinning off over they've all been spin
an off up for a while so one a year is
fine I'm sure they're Disney sitting
there writing this down going well the
[ __ ] one guy from Jay and Silent Bob
says one a year is fine maybe that's
what we should do but one a year seems
to be fine
cramming them too close together they're
gonna have a car wreck like they have
with solo where you never want people
[ __ ] on Star Wars or yelling from
the sidelines though you [ __ ] up like
you can't be that it's a legacy brand
it's an American [ __ ] product right
like [ __ ] baseball and apple pie and
[ __ ] and like them goddamn Star Wars
as American as it gets and stuff so you
know [ __ ] it has to be it's true it's
wasn't filmed in America but well the
guy who made it it was an American so
counts thank you half the people have
accents but we just all want the best
for Star Wars right we do maybe that
didn't [ __ ] you know maybe Solo felt
made people think like aw [ __ ]
we're in trouble but III don't think so
and I don't think they should pull back
on the reins or I don't know what you do
I've never ridden a horse I don't think
they should slow the horse down I don't
think they should speed headlong into
like we're [ __ ] makin well see they
could make a Ben Kenobi movie even
though Alec Guinness is around because
we had three movies where you and
McGregor was Ben Kenobi so [ __ ] give
us that movie and there's a movie that
ties into [ __ ] like not just the
classic Star Wars trilogy but also the
prequel trilogy z-- which had their
audience even though everyone likes to
[ __ ] on a be like [ __ ] Georgia like
they're a bunch of kids that love those
movies and for them that is [ __ ] and
so I think they can get away with that I
think there's a lot they could keep
doing just you can't hopefully like this
puts to rest any ideas like I heard on
the internet one point yeah they could
get sebastian stand to do a young Luke
Skywalker movie and I was like they
already made the young Luke Skywalker
movies called [ __ ] Star Wars man like
you don't get a younger version than
that otherwise it's like this is the
come that made Luke like look at it swim
credits you know so and I like Sebastian
Stan please Internet don't turn that
into a story of Smith's shits on
Sebastian Stan I'm just saying like now
we've seen with Han Solo in the solo
movie don't don't touch the those three
characters that's apparently that's
sacrosanct they don't want their on
their Luke or their Leia touched and and
touch the rest they're all ageless
touching experience wherever you
whatever you want
they're they're all you know like robots
and monsters and makeups that will never
age so you get away with yeah I think
that the truth of what they're gonna do
is just sort of re-examine the way they
make these but how often like you said
they make these and at what price they
make these because they spend this [ __ ]
ton of money on solo granted they spent
twice as much as they would like to
because they made two movies yes so I
think going forward it's just okay these
are not going to be episodes so we can't
spend episode money on these but you
could make one of these for eighty
million dollars as opposed to 150
million dollars and just make the
margins better
that's why they'd be crazy not to let
what's-his-name James Mangold they said
is working on a boba fett movie right
and James Mangold made [ __ ] magic
with the Logan movie had a low budget
that was not a pricey [ __ ] film now
I'm not saying like you let Boba Fett
cuff buckers heads off and [ __ ] although
that would be metal as [ __ ] but cuz I
know it's Disney they're like we don't
want to do that as our Raiden ship but
but you that guy's a great storyteller
man that far he's always made wonderful
movies that theft
I hate westerns in that 310 or 410 or
whatever 10 to Yuma
is a fantastic [ __ ] I'm not good
enough to remember the title but the
Yuma movie is really [ __ ] good what
would Batman in it yes that's right
Batman wasn't it and the angel so ie
that guy's a great [ __ ] storyteller
let him take boba fett make it cheap
like make it for 15 million bucks it's
all upside nobody's ever once gonna sit
there and be like oh I wish they'd spent
more money as long as the story's
[ __ ] compelling people don't know
what budgets are normal people only
freaks like us pay attention to what she
had caused [ __ ] that we have nothing to
do with you know but fans do that like
how basketball fans know how what
everyone makes and [ __ ] on just got paid
to show up in LA LeBron James got traded
to the Lakers by the way oh yeah that's
a good thing just like LeBron was he was
for my own edification he was in
Cleveland used a Cleveland company went
to Florida at one point yeah and people
were like he left us [ __ ] back in
Cleveland and won them a championship
and now is coming to LA for 154 million
dollars over four years to play
basketball yeah
I made a lot of wrong choices man [ __ ]
Wow really so this is how he's gonna end
his career in Los Cabos isn't that I
mean I'm not a big sports guy but isn't
that generally what out goes at leats
they're like I play hard with the city
for a while some of them finished with
that city but some are like I want to
finish out my career in the lap of
luxury totally so I can come out here
and be an actor and take meetings on my
off days wasn't he in a movie train
wreck or something yeah yeah is that he
was good so there you go that's all I
was that what they're doing I mean this
is not medicine so this is complete
ignorance I know he must be a great
basketball player because I've heard of
his name but is he still a great best
moment he's still pretty good
so LA is like our Lakers fans happy or
no not over there it's so weird how like
the it's in this room and maybe it's
just because we're this show like it
like the audience was like a woman we
met at the bar and we were doing
fantastic with her and then all sudden
we started talking about sports and she
was like [ __ ] this and just [ __ ] walk
away let's get back on track yeah every
had led with like Greg Berlanti got 400
million dollars to stay at Warner
Brothers it was like Oh Greg Berlanti
didn't really know yeah that made my
[ __ ] wet am i April auntie Lou tell me
more did he get that much yeah is that
one of the stories no it was like a
month ago one gonna have a go what
happened what do you get for hundred
million dollars to stay at Warner
Brothers TV to produce more shows than
anybody's ever done at one time in the
history of TV everything I've ever done
is wrong man like I was feeling good
about my life until this is [ __ ]
episode wow that's a lot of money and
you know what god bless him because he
makes shows that I like and he picks
great talent surrounds himself with
wonderful people and I [ __ ] oh I'm no
[ __ ] I'm not just saying this
because we're here or [ __ ] around a
geek show but like probably one of the
last things I'll think about before I
leave this world will be one of those
episodes of the flash and Supergirl
there's the stories like being [ __ ] so
much news so
credibly touching and [ __ ]
adventurous and [ __ ] like that I've
talked about a zillion times so he can
have all the [ __ ] money so I'm going
to have it all four hundred million
dollars Warner Brothers is like did you
hear that but one guy from Jay and
Silent Bob said we did the right thing
Oh God
wow that's that's not even one of the
news stories no it's [ __ ] news to me
cuz it was on the heels of Ryan Murphy
getting 300 million dollars to go to
Netflix Greg got more yeah that's Wow
because Netflix I'm sure would have
opened up the [ __ ] bank for him as
well but Warner Brothers says well you
do 9 shows for us now we want you to
keep making shows it's worth it for us
to keep you in terrestrial television
when they say something like 400 million
is that like the budget to make the
shows or that's just like here's your
four hundred million the way like Don
Johnson drives around with eight million
in bearer bonds Larry what he gets paid
that's that that's [ __ ] you know what
that's this is one of those situations
where I'm like happy for the guy like he
does good work like and it's nice to see
good work and get rewarded and [ __ ] so
good for him yeah so that's not one of
our stories this week there's a story to
me I'm gonna [ __ ] text him after this
and be like can I have a job can I count
your money do me help carrying your
money just yeah like I'll be Johnson all
right on to the next piece of music next
thing you know they're making a Morbius
movie right
[ __ ] yeah I saw that man yeah make it up
for those that don't follow cuz that's
like old school but I mean I guess he's
been around Morbius the living vampire
is a marvel comics character
guess what he is and they're making a
movie about it
Jared Leto is going to play Morbius saw
that too man so he's the Joker and he's
Morbius there are other actors do you
think I'm number one I'm happy for him
good for him then there'll be a cool
role for him to play but do you think
that other Joker movie that they talked
about a few weeks ago as a
ality or you think it's something they
just said because anytime they talk
about a joker movie you know maybe Jared
Leto's rep so like he's the Joker
[ __ ] yeah remember and so maybe that
just put out there like oh no it's gonna
happen for sure is I can't imagine like
why me I guess Josh Brolin is in
Deadpool and [ __ ] infinity war so I
guess actors can do double time but I
mean can I would like to say that we
will see this Joker movie just after we
see the cyborg movie which one the Leto
Joker yeah I think we're gonna see the
Todd Phillips one with what's name that
looks like it's happen I think so but I
just I don't and again like we talked
about her last time that I don't want a
joke Emily I want Harley Quinn vs. the
Joker movie I want him to be a
supporting character in somebody else's
movie but I don't need to see him just
be like here's my story which is not
what the Joker says what if he's doing
it with that performance critics alike
we thought the Joker was bad under letõs
watch mark barnard inprint it to a new
low mark a of the marks I am NOT Hamill
to be fair all right so so yeah they're
making that for reasons people seem I
mean like kids like vampires vampires
are you know [ __ ] you go always sell a
vampire movie there's a Marvel vampire
man that's even talking easier to sell
right you're like hey kids you like
vampires well this one no spider-man you
know can't believe that they're gonna
[ __ ] make a Morbius movies if you
told me [ __ ] ten years ago one day
they're gonna make more views movie I
feel like maybe it'll be a Morpheus
movie they spin it out of the [ __ ]
matrix and [ __ ] but they'll never be a
Morbius movie and here we are it's like
would you like to know what the bottom
of the barrel looks like Morbius
I don't look I'm never call him top
shelf but like you know he is he's a
well-known Marvel character he's the
well vodka [ __ ] serious shell but
you'll drink it of its diluted with
enough [ __ ]
I'm curious who's doing this movie Sony
is it part of the soul of the spider-man
universe he's kind of yeah they haven't
revealed whether or not Tom Hollands
spider-man will show up in it II hope so
yeah I will I met Tom Holland last
weekend I did the Ace Comic Con in
Seattle and I moderated panels and so I
moderated a panel with Paul Bettany and
Elizabeth Olsen a vision and the scarlet
the Scarlet Witch panel is lovely then I
moderated a panel with Grant Gustin the
flash is lovely and then I have finished
off with first was me and Sebastian Stan
then anthony mackie joined us and then
Tom Holland came out and he announced
well he had done it on his Instagram the
title of the next spider-man movie is
spider-man : far from home ooh so first
one was spider-man homecoming second
when Spiderman far from home third one
will be spider-man home sweet home I
don't know home of the break a pattern
here but so that was kind of exciting
and stuff but he's a nice kid polite as
[ __ ] British as it gets man I forgot I'm
so used to watch it and be like so is
there money involved with this mr. stalk
and [ __ ] like that I was giving him
props and I talked to him man I was like
that [ __ ] Queens accent as I've been
watching people do spider-man for years
not like that kid get your mind out of
the gutter I said but watching people
play spider-man for years I said you're
the first one and it was ever like well
why doesn't he sound like he's from
where he's from
and he was like thanks he's gone but I
had to make up for this accent so I was
like I guess you got a point there good
point nice kid man
anyway and this far from home thing is
going to take place at least some of it
overseas right I think it's at the same
London or something like that as well
and apparently the villain is gonna be
Mysterio which rocks and it's Jake
Gyllenhaal yeah but it this makes me a
little nervous when they cast the super
famous actor a well-known actor
as the villain because then they're
gonna be tempted to show his face all
the time
and with Mysterio I don't want to see no
face I was gonna see that [ __ ] bowl
the whole time you know [ __ ] seeing his
face but you know he's a great actor I'm
sure we'll pull it off or maybe this is
the sweetest paycheck that Jake
Gyllenhaal ever had I know you know what
I'm gonna be on a set like three days
total
could you imagine he's like man I'm
gonna Robert Downey jr. that [ __ ] I must
sit in a dark room that put a camera in
my face and I'd be like no spider-man no
life is illusory out with eight billion
dollars in bearer bonds [ __ ] John
Johnson's my agent recalibrates your
sense of what money is when John Johnson
gets his hands on eight I mean I thought
you said eight million the first time I
think you're like eight billion and
nobody followed up on that story I think
we landed on the moon right after that
all right I'm in support of this Morbius
movie man all right one of the Marvel
vampires dude there's only one step away
from Marvel Zombies and the undead in
the Marvel Universe you know we're gonna
talk about now tell me Batman
that's a novelty who is this Batman you
talk about Batman and good character
without which this podcast doesn't exist
when my favorite [ __ ] characters of
all time and whatnot what's going on in
the world of Batman Sam Keith the
wonderful artist wonderful artist who
created the max way back in the day also
did some Sam man if I remember correctly
handsome Batman stuff yeah he is one of
those wonderful bats with the long
pointy ears he is returning to the max
for the first time in 20 years in a
crossover with Batman what the max is
gonna fight Batman Wow
Jesse yeah that's like Batman fighting
the Hulk essentially that was his kind
of version of the Hulk wasn't yeah yeah
it's not to be diminish it I don't want
[ __ ] Internet's like [ __ ] Smith
shits on Keith I'm a huge Sam Keith game
but I mean it was like if I remember
that character correctly he's [ __ ]
very hunky yeah and like very like Lenny
a little bit from a mice and men who
like there was some tell me about the
rabbits George yeah like there was
mental illness involved there was
Asylum thing and so this five issue
series from DC and IDW will find the max
in Arkham Asylum oh that's a good idea
yeah oh my god I wasn't interested until
you said that now I'm like oh I know
what Arkham Asylum is didn't the Mac
seven MTV cartoon he did yeah which is
awesome yeah I was really mad I sort of
early days of liquid television yeah and
the max is called yeah Wow good for him
man yes returned into his old characters
that's real nice yeah so I think that's
coming either late this year or early
next year September it's one thing to
take your character out of mothballs and
play with them for the first time in a
long time it must be nice for him to be
like well at least I get to play with
Batman - so like somebody's gonna give a
[ __ ] now just be good for him man that's
cool yeah and that my friend is all the
news that's fit to print that's
everything that's everything I we're not
a visually oriented show but I will
point out that I saw a photo of Kristen
Wiig as dr. Minerva
Yi who eventually becomes cheetah I
guess what's the director put it any
Jenkins yes she must have right drop
drop in images but that made me very
excited that of course she's not dressed
like cheetah or anything like that but I
look forward to this movies movies
getting me amped yeah and I think
they're bringing some footage to
comic-con oh yeah yeah that's right
because they're shooting off could you
imagine if they show just the little
cheetah it's probably too early to do
that but I know something I'm so [ __ ]
onboard no fingers crossing for Martian
Manhunter yeah I like your theory I hope
that's the case I Aquaman is the big
premiere in all ages they're gonna show
yeah but I think there might be a little
something something of Wonder Woman
right I'm gonna know I'm heading out
there of course this year with the IMDB
yet again I'll be on the IMD boat
interviewing people left and right and
movers and shakers and [ __ ] people
way above my pay grade sitting there
gone how do you get so famous [ __ ] like
that
they get some shiny council rock people
on the boat yeah yeah
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo would they send
from the cast I'm not sure if they
finalized anything yet but it would
surprise me to death if bill skarsgård
doesn't roll in
I met him up at Sundance with the IMDB
yes oh yeah freakishly tall like [ __ ]
well I wouldn't go that far Jesus [ __ ]
so I and Finn and like elfin ly handsome
like it Swedish tennis model is it
really live and like weird and Hollow
cheese the longer I stand next to you
the more I figure out your type like you
know like look at Ron type here you know
really tall and ethereal and weird
he's good-looking man so he'll be he
probably the person but I think they'll
have more of the cats there and the show
rentals will be there and [ __ ] Spacek
in the show maybe might be her first
comic-con as far as I know I mean but
she's in the show she's announced that
to the big show but she's in the big
show that'd be amazing if they brought
her to comic-con I might be the only one
in the audience going I [ __ ] love Coal
Miner's Daughter Carrie all right so
that's the news part of the show ladies
and gentlemen now we come to part of the
show that's really fun for for us and we
give away fabulous prizes the Q a part
of fat man on Batman ladies gentlemen
where you get to dive deep into the the
cobwebs of our minds what we have here
in marks hot little hands are five sets
of tickets fine no doubt for a for DX
cinema at la live ladies and gentlemen
if you have never seen a for DX movie or
movie in for DX I should say I'm not
just saying this because they give us a
promotional consideration give out
tickets and stuff that's nice for you
all and stuff wait there's no [ __ ]
money exchanging hands here I'm just a
fan of the service I want to see a movie
in it and [ __ ] snowed in the movie snow
in the [ __ ] theater I said oh my god
is the end of the world they said no
it's technology
[ __ ] and so so the rapture who where
is the horns of Jericho and she'll like
that and so 40x if you haven't seen a
[ __ ] movie in it my god go see it
here on fat man I'm Batman what we do
and also first off thanks to our good
friend Brett Deacon to give this tickets
give it up for deacon what we do how you
can get these tickets ladies and
gentlemen is you ask a question and if
your question is good enough deemed good
enough this is the judgy part of the
show if we deem your question good
enough you get to walk away with a set
of two tickets to go see a 40 X and
movie any movie you want to see the 4dx
theater playing it here in town at LA
Live but I believe the tickets you can
probably use another 48 states like one
in Chicago no no not at all
you guys you tried to use it in another
city can tears you [ __ ] looked it up
and [ __ ]
kind of free time you have man we're
like I wonder how far these tickets will
travel I see carriers everywhere not
just here man I saw where were the last
time we saw each other in Seattle that's
right we took pictures of the Ace Comic
Con my god and I said why don't we just
do it in the back alley next time which
sounds dirtier than I meant everybody
you know taking pictures gotta change
that back alley man all right so what we
got here is an opportunity folks the
only rule we have is that the question
you ask has to be askable to both me and
mark barnard nothing like what's it like
to be Silent Bob mark doesn't know do
you
a finer piece of scrapped it on-the-spot
comedy you won't see all we've well done
sir well done okay as always JC the
proprietor this here find establishment
give it up for JC JC got a mic in his
hand he picks the people on the first
one he picks his Big Daddy Jimmy P give
it up for him ladies a Jonah Oh aye ya
wetter than the finest of kilts what
yeah look at you rocking the [ __ ] kilt
I didn't look down I'm a neck up kind of
guy he called my attention to that [ __ ]
what wow what does it feel like people
always tell me like why don't you rock
it kill you know what it's it's really
nice breezy yeah and perfect weather for
two here in LA so today wasn't you yeah
just as good as shorts but just no
center divider yeah I like a little
buffer between my thighs Robins racing I
guess so sure but I can't make fun of
how to anybody dresses because I just my
way but I think that looks good man but
I think I'm I tried to pull that off my
wife would be like I'm leaving now
there's like evil is [ __ ] hoodie
sweatshirt and I've lived through
[ __ ] bass basketball shooters and
hockey jerseys and she's like you've
always been a terrible dresser but if
you start wearing skirts and you look
better than me
[ __ ] you there's an old Sam Jackson
called the 51st state I think it was yes
where he plays a [ __ ] international
drug dealer or whatever it is but he's
always wearing a kilt and the only
reason he took the role was because he
said I want to wear kilts if you if you
write me in this movie that I'm wearing
nothing but [ __ ] kilts I'll do your
movie like [ __ ] yes mam it's just
nothing but kills he plays golf without
the entire [ __ ] picture could you
imagine coming to a point in your career
where you're like I've done it all what
happened
I haven't worn a kilt the whole [ __ ]
movie I want to get kilt
that's how he ends up in Star Wars was
like listen I'll do it George if you
give me a purple lightsaber yes if I
don't get a purple lightsaber I'm not
gonna do your [ __ ] movie it's like
well they only come in red blue and
green like purple all right purple
there's that his favorite color yeah
yeah and like that's he's the only Jedi
that's got a purple lightsaber before
since Wow it said bad [ __ ] on it
no it did not did it on the hilt Wow all
right back to you big guy uh recent
which we talked about the new season of
Luke Cage and in it in the later
episodes there's a scene where Danny and
Luke are in a head shop together
Danny admires a pipe and it's like oh I
like this one and Luke casually says oh
you smoke and they kind of just leave it
at that
my question for you is given the
opportunity to convince Kevin Feige to
introduce the greenery into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe who would you argue
should be the smoker Doctor Strange the
name says it all
dr. strange to be such a hardcore smoker
smoker that when he met Groot he should
have been like I want to smoke that but
him the mad at me of the master of
mystical arts I would imagine that would
that would make sense for me you the
watcher yeah [ __ ] yeah because how
boring is that job like I gotta be
blazed I'm gonna sit on this [ __ ]
moon and watch [ __ ] forever yeah you
just sitting there watching [ __ ] and
you're like what [ __ ] Steve Rogers is
[ __ ] he'll hide your [ __ ] this always
back [ __ ] what a great question [ __ ]
give it up for him you get tickets
charge we got another one what's your
name my name's Sam take us there Sam
where we're going I'm so I'm a huge
Batman fan and I love the Joker like
favorite villain all-time and I just saw
a while ago I read the white night
series and I forget Fred it's really
really good and in it the Joker kind of
like becomes good for a while come into
sever Waring's good and Batman gets
portrayed more as a villain so I thought
that was a super cool concept Oh white
knight the white knight it's an eight
eight part mini zero
I forget the name Sean Murtagh Murphy
runner yeah really good though I'm sure
now you just sold it sweet so my
question is if you could switch any
super hero and villain so that they were
the opposite of superhero villain who
would you choose hmm so kind of like how
what Marvel was stuck Doc Ock and
spider-man that also sounds dirtier than
a message there were at one point when
Spiderman had doc Ock's mind and yeah
I'm like that thanks are you talking
about that or just um I mean like okay
so all an example would be like if
Superman was evil but Lex Luthor was
good right that's but yeah they've done
that but so like if you could choose any
one okay it doesn't even have to be it
could be DC Marvel you could switch I
like you you're too
can I can I go outside of DC and marvel
yeah yeah anyone
I think Captain Hook is the good guy and
I think Peter Pan is a [ __ ] menace a
menace who keeps kidnap children and
[ __ ] like that you know hook is
handicapped and nobody treats him like
that nobody gives him any consideration
and stuff like that and he's a hell of a
dresser so a self self-made man you know
and I'm saying captain of his own
destiny I can make the argument for hook
and pan being a real [ __ ] you I worked
on Superman Lex Luthor that was a pole
that's a really good poem because I
think that that in Lex's mind he is
already Superman in Lex's mind he
believes he's the hero of Metropolis I
like the versions of the stories they do
with Lex where he was the number one
metropolis his favorite son until
Superman came along and most of his
character flaw comes from the hubris of
not being able to be number two right
those the compelling ones I like when
he's a scientist shed and [ __ ] like
the Lex killing suit and stuff like that
but I I do like it when there's
something tragic about it like this
could have been a great man but instead
he lost his mind because there was a
greater man right and there's always a
greater man but that's the problem with
somebody Lex Lex Luthor he's like no I'm
the greatest man I'm the one yeah so
instead I'm going to go Grand Moff
Tarkin and Princess Leia ooh do tell
explain because I'm the terrorist she's
a terrorist and not for nothing but
Osama bin Laden
can't be too soon the man's dead but you
know the Empire is a really well-run
organization like you know the trains
run on time like there's the the supply
lines are legit like everybody's fed
nobody really kind of wants me they once
you've been unsubdued and unn crunched
by the the clad boots of the empire it's
kind of not bad and then here comes this
[ __ ] like rogue terrorists you
blowing [ __ ] up and aren't happy with
the regime that we're building in here
everybody gets what they want everybody
wins as long as you you know agreed to
imperial rule the awesome thing is you
don't even have to change the title
it'll Star Wars
there's still the Rebel Alliance but
yeah I think that that's why we go in a
world where Disney has to keep making
these movies till the end of time make
that like you know make it like a
what-if version of like would it [ __ ]
the rebels were bad look at this [ __ ]
who wouldn't go see that movie like even
if people were like there's a sacrilege
everything Star Wars was man you'd still
be like to please like you'd want to see
how sacrilegious it was that sounds
[ __ ] amazing I like your answer
better than mine but I like your
question better than both answers give
it up first you won tickets right now JC
give us somebody else man leave that
free tickets yay come on up what you got
take your time what's with that playboys
hey is it with mine who's in it me and
Jason oh that was the one I signed I
didn't see the cover [ __ ] I'm stupid
just there was literally playboy there
the whole time but then I saw you
walking with one I was a gue such a
teenage boy is like Playboy
you know I got naked ladies in that
thing do you think you just came from
the woods or stag in the woods oh my god
that's a reference that will die with
our generation I know like kids like you
try to explain to a kid when we were
kids if you found a [ __ ] stack of
Playboy's in the woods it was like the
greatest thing that ever happened like
why was that the greatest thing they
were average like cuz we cuz you could
see naked language no internet and they
were like what happened in the internet
there was no internet there was no
internet you have to go in the woods
with your friends and jerk off together
I just do that with my friends online
and Facebook you switch for that anyway
what's your name sorry my name is Ryan
Velasquez and well give it up a Ryan
ladies jamun look what do you got for us
Ryan alright so a timeless questions we
use ass on deployment was wait
deployment what branch
US Marines I won't give it up for a
Malaysia so a times question we used to
have I have a couple buddies who are
huge nerds but we always use ass like
hoop would late the lightsaber first was
it Han or kylo and we always go and
debate between that said what was the
question who bought the lightsaber was
it Han or kylo who hold it like well I
mean woo-hoo-hoo-hoo knighted it who
sparked it was at Han or kylo yes great
question
I'm very well I mean logic dictates it
was kylo but was it really though I
think it was lime juice wasn't enough to
have this conversation
personally I think it was Han explain
well because I didn't well Kylie didn't
want to go to the dark side he was kind
of in between yeah he was away on the
foot you know everybody has their own
opinions I'm not about to start a huge
spark you can
that is a true statement but me
personally I think it was Han because
Kyle was good and if you go between
non-canon you know the true stories you
know it tells that han wasn't really
that bad his kids weren't that bad oh
the twins that they had in the extended
universe stories are so but so but why
would Han ignite it himself to the save
kylo but why would that save him
wouldn't that push him to the dark side
because he was like because what is it
the old order is you're almost did you
get me though I think you're onto
something here well I do understand what
he's saying I understand what he's
saying but I'm having a hard time
understanding why the Han Solo who
promised Leia that he would bring their
son back
maybe that's well I mean like there's
bringing the son back physically and
maybe he's like I'll bring our son back
and his point is what if Han was like if
I [ __ ] take the saber like look at
the kid clearly wants to kill me but it
doesn't want to kill me if I make the
decision for him perhaps that [ __ ]
like it shocks his system and he's like
I don't want to be a bad guy but then in
the next movie he's like I'm gonna kill
my mom with the second movie but yeah I
mean what an interesting take I hadn't
thought about that you I hadn't thought
about it either I'm still not really
thinking about it now I just try to
follow I'm Jenna follow the character
logic of how that makes it a victory for
Han Solo how what he sacrificed himself
to save his son's soul and it doesn't
say there's some soul because what well
the movies aren't over yet that's true
what if like right before the [ __ ]
third right in the third act of the next
movie of episode was seven eight nine
Episode nine [ __ ] you know kylo Ren
has a chance to [ __ ] strike down
who's left to kill Rey and dropping
bodies so they're [ __ ] left and right
and so instead you know he's like oh but
[ __ ] he remembers that moment [ __ ]
he's like it hurt my feelings to kill my
dad and he turned you know I'm not the
writer somebody else and come up with
better
and they turns the [ __ ] Eliza brought
that would totally work then oh my soul
yeah ouchy my soul moment I could see it
kind of working and I'm not likely but I
guess I guess it's a steep dive to pull
out if it's possible but but it's it's
like captain Sully landing the plane on
the [ __ ] right Hudson River like you
could do it but only 19 out of 100 times
you crash and you kill everybody but
that's what would have happened I think
that's the the math they put out in
Sully it's like every time the computer
did it everybody dies every time we've
run these sinners everybody dies you're
the one anomaly here that means that
everybody lives so how did you do the
impossible I'm telling you you got to
read the news too because I didn't give
a [ __ ] about that story but the first
time in my life I'm like that is pretty
dramatically should show me good good
[ __ ] storyteller um that [ __ ] what he
says I thought it was a great question
you win tickets give it up for plays
gentlemen right here take these tickets
thank you Ron want to sing it's your
ticket
remember the prize man the prize I had
your back there you go what that uh here
we go what's your name captain hey my
name is Ross Ross yes I'll give it up
for us how you guys doing
[Applause]
Ross like a boss take us where you want
to go so Kevin I met you five years ago
I was at comic-con
met you in the halls I was actually at a
really shitty part in my life oh and you
gave me some awesome awesome advice
about following my dreams and my
passions you basically said just [ __ ]
do it man so I did five years later I
launched my comic book online I brought
you a poster it's in the frame Oh
[Music]
yah-ha post-apocalyptic taco truck yeah
it's all dudes man max its Deadpool
meets Mad Max tall in a taco truck tell
us a little bit more about it we're done
from the idea so it came from being down
and out and smoking a lot of weed eating
a lot of tacos at the taco trucks here
in LA but basically it's a story about a
crazy
kamikaze chef Eddie who's the human his
simian sidekick Sanchez who's hyper
intelligent just a badass he's the
silent bob - Eddie's Jay and they
basically are cruising across the
wasteland in their armored taco truck
towards a transdimensional cook-off
against Satan's chef yeah it's [ __ ]
dope man
you put Satan in this [ __ ] I put
Satan in it I put a version of Gordon
hemmed Gordon Gordon Ramsay in it you
put two Satan's in this [ __ ]
Guy Fieri is in the third episode Satan
the holy [ __ ] Paula Deen in the second
earth oh my god man yeah I hate on a
little bit of the cooking Network people
yeah but yeah you you you kind of gave
me the drive I got together with my
friend who's a tattoo artist down in
Anaheim Aleister Gill grim amazing
artist we hammered it out and we just
launched it online and you guys go check
it out what is the website address of
those it's PA TT comic calm Pat comic
calm yeah T's impact yeah
post-apocalyptic taco truck yeah it's an
acronym it's like NASA it is yeah and we
we released pages every Tuesday and
Thursday and then we have a page round
so if you want to help us out a buck a
month gets you access to the comic of a
month early well can I have you at home
man there you go buck a goddamn so thank
you so much for basically saving my life
I didn't save your life look what you
did look what you did I was right you
made me smart give it up for me
so my question both of you I had
something that was about diversity in
the film industry but I love hearing you
guys wax poetic about how a film could
be or how it should go
we were just talking about Crete - I had
a couple of beers with some friends a
while back and we were talking about it
after the trailer came out how does the
movie end in your minds oh what a great
question you know I like this question
because it gives him an opportunity to
write I like watching them right I don't
think I'd like to watch him write in
real life it'd be boring but watching
him right on the fly is always oh you
don't no no it's I I write amazingly
entertaining Lee do you you dancing and
[ __ ] like [ __ ] Ralph playing the
piano and the Muppets I sound like Al
Jarreau in the word [ __ ] I'm coming
over to watch you really saying how does
Cretu end or how does it actually like
what do you see it happening throughout
thought I think I think I think Tessa
Thompson's character goes deaf oh good
point the actor she was losing her here
I think that happened and she was its
degenerative so by the end of it she
can't make music anymore I well here's
what I would love to happen I would love
for this movie to end with with Adonis
Creed knocking out Ivan Drago I want to
see him beat the [ __ ] out of Dolph
Lundgren in a parking lot that's what in
apartment was in a parking lot I want to
see it happen like after the fighter oh
wait so let me follow so whatever
happens to ring you and give a [ __ ] but
you want to see right because that would
never happen in the ring
Adonis B Ivan Drago yes kill him or beat
him like I think beat him within an inch
of his life that is [ __ ] number one
plushie number two that is a [ __ ]
awesome like and it also borrows from
rocky wasn't there were live live into
the street fight yeah look I think if
that would never be sanctioned in the
ring so that's never gonna be the
ultimate fight but I think like almost
killing the dude who killed your dad
feels like it feels like something
poetic there that was that's a good
right there [ __ ] that's a good ending to
a movie that makes me want to see the
next one and [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying like a whole [ __ ] and or take it
one step further can I improve upon his
idea yeah it does [ __ ] kill him and
the next movie is him in jail it's the
fight for his life
just three three three three Supermax
yeah Penitentiary's wow that was [ __ ]
a good question but don't you think it
would be better if better than what I
just said yes it can be good okay so
what was the biggest problem with the
fight between Apollo and Drago apollo
dies yeah
rocky doesn't throw in the towel what if
the fight goes to that point and he's
like I can't let another create die he
throws the towel in Creede leaves
without that victory I'm sorry I brought
you I want to see your movie it's
awesome keep gone so he ends on a down
note it's another loss but at the
beginning of the film he's a cocky boxer
he's what's that thus the starts the
matrix tour yes but he's rich he's how
all the kids are saying these days like
this starts with matrix for [ __ ]
but he's rich he's talking he's got the
family started nothing can touch him and
then and that was kind of like rocky and
rocky 3 right yeah he's got the robot
that was Scarface what was the [ __ ]
song that they sang the montage song
when he was like getting at when they
showed him being rich and [ __ ] I don't
remember it was this was it was an eye
of the tiger Wow that's three I have the
tiger so that's I'm talking about that's
what he goes back to he goes to LA
that's when they play out of the tiger
but in the beginning when they're Shawn
like he has a good life before clubber
Lang I got a robot yes yeah happy
birthday Pauling
that's what [ __ ] creed 3 could be
they fight that robot fine I like that
that's [ __ ] dope so there's a moment
where they're fightin and [ __ ] and like
Adonis is getting his ass kicked by a
Drago jr. and Stallone remembers not
throwing in the towel and Stallone rocky
remembers not throwing the towel and
then throws the towel in and then at
dawn this is like you piece of [ __ ] I
could have [ __ ] took a breeze like
Youku Tudou and Creed 3 but Creed 3 then
opens up with a massive rift between
these two so you got somewhere to go
with the story well I mean I wouldn't
take that - Creed 3 right cuz nobody
wants to leave Creed - going oh they're
not friends anymore so that fight has to
happen midway through maybe and the web
end of second and the first act or
something like that or so that it gives
you time for them to oh oh it's about to
get better because I think like if I'm
the people that made [ __ ] Creed I'm
really scared right because I'm like
these are all good movies or he doesn't
throw in the towel because rocky dies Oh
[Music]
drop your microphone drop it right now
oh my god that'd be [ __ ] amazing then
you get some of that burgess Meredith
yeah Mickey going on like it he loses
the fight and so that you got a train
for the rematch oh my god
[Music]
here but we know that one that will hear
that would be amazing but Stallone is
his hubris too big to let that happen I
mean he rewrote it out of Creed blushes
there was supposed to be like he got the
cancer he was supposed to die in Creed
and maybe there's a better way that's
also not strong sounds like a speech at
the end of rocky for maybe there's a
better way if I you were say it's two
guys in here won't you teach on the face
but we could be better that would be
pretty much a [ __ ] that all look I'm in
for that movie cuz that trailer was good
all of this is [ __ ] those are fun
movies that I wish we were going to be
seen it's probably not gonna be the case
what is the one of everything we've just
spoken about I think his is the closest
I think there's a moment where he could
[ __ ] throw in the tub that makes
sense to me like in terms of like if you
got it you got a drawback to that movie
right if you're gonna bring Drago into
it and to [ __ ] in the trailer they
show rocky being like you can't because
of this in history so obviously it means
a lot to him I think yours is the most
[ __ ] likely yours is the most [ __ ]
amazing
and mine is well I think the robot fight
could be cool I like both of your
versions better those are the version
where you doesn't go in the towel and
then you get at Donna's fighting Rocky
they can't do that he's too old man
that's abuse but still that would be
abuse exactly i mean i don't know i
don't think i don't yeah i don't think
he's like a big fight but i think
there's the you know like a square
diamond something like that and he's
like yo or you know [ __ ] that was a good
question to resolve the lots of great
answers you wouldn't give it up Rod's
thank you take some tickets
graduation that's awesome thank you
alright one more hey see we got one set
it's a good what if rocky dies at the
end of Act one get into the position to
ask what if Barack he dies at the end of
Act one yes and Drago's kid is the
badass but he's estranged from his
father and then his father shows up
after rocky dies seems like there's only
one guy who can train you to beat this
Punk and honest to kill his own son and
I think we have all collectively made
the best rocky movie ever made man that
is awesome give it up for JC [ __ ] they
get fungal lips out of retirement
oh yeah well that's what I figured once
they showed Drago you know that Creed 3
mr. t still around so they could totally
pull oh yeah totally pull a clubber lang
card and they'll have me again where I'm
like I don't care anymore in the end one
will be like I pity the fool like take
all my money what if what if what if
Adrian did actually like take clubber up
I only was like hey yeah one real man
I'll show you real man like yes I do and
suddenly there is now like biracial
clubber lang jr. out of the woodwork to
be sure don't [ __ ] on Adrian like that
her love for Rocky was real man it was
real but she's watching the [ __ ]
Apollo Creed and his fine black ass
running up and down the beach and
swimming in the pool happened during the
training of cover lang oh yeah when he
was all ageru you do and he's all
[ __ ] yellow to do and she's a guy you
work it out ok Carla are you doing I
think you wrote the sexiest version of
Rocky I still like the other versions
better meanwhile we got a guest what's
your name my friend my name is Bohannon
Bo it's parasailing and Bo him Bohannon
Bo hat yeah I'm the only boy
what's your question where can we take
you sir where can you take us oh well I
kind of wanted to keep it in the vein of
rootin for the bad guy because if you
look at like the last few movies for
like the last decade or so the ones that
have really become classics almost
instantly are the ones where the hero is
either like at a parallel or inferior to
the bad guy
I mean look what we got Joker in the
Dark Knight kill monger and black
panther I mean it just runs the gamut
but what I would really like to see is
the story of Vader after he really
becomes Vader I mean cuz they kind of
screwed up the prequels so my question
to you guys is if they made a Vader as
Vader trilogy or series how would they
be able to do it and where could they go
as far as moving it into the rest of the
epic of Star Wars what a great question
let's talk about what you could do with
a Star Wars movie that essentially picks
up where episode 3 ends no basically you
just have to make up for that moment and
so what can my we've seen him be the
badass in rogue one yes so we see for
the time between him becoming Darth
Vader and that moment is what in the
movies 10 20 years or whatever [ __ ]
let's say 10 18 bang so 18 years
difference between that period so you
got 18 years that he got that you know
that all of Jesus's Lost years you know
they cover him when he was a kid and
then they pick him up when he's in his
30s
yeah like what happened in his 20s like
he had a couple bad girlfriends
that's not a pertinent to the story so
you could do that here there's lots of
[ __ ] material the tailgators bad
girlfriends but the idea of like him
becoming like now that he's crossed over
more machine than man more lap dog for
the emperor than anything else and stuff
and watch his descent like you know we
saw him in the beginning as a what now
feels like I wouldn't go so far as a
cartoonish but like you know a movie bad
guy where are the plans and stuff and
then in wrote one [ __ ] 20 years later
30 years later they showed us how
[ __ ] horrible the dude could be so
let's see that let's see like this the
dropping of the humanity more machine
than man coming to terms with like I
guess what you're talking about they did
in Luke Cage like she can't put her
fingers in the trigger and [ __ ] like
that this is a guy who's just learning
to control a body I mean I know it was a
movie and [ __ ] but it was so weird at
the end of that movie when he gets up
and he's like no because he'd just come
off an operating table man after I had a
heart attack I laid around for like two
days and [ __ ] this guy got put together
from lava and he was like I'm back so I
think you would you could tell a very
compelling story about dealing with the
agony that's like every once in a while
they like hint it like it aint [ __ ]
pretty being Darth Vader but you could
really [ __ ] tell the story of how like
[ __ ] agonizing it is to breathe out
this [ __ ] wanted to die on
Mustafar and [ __ ] and somehow he's
[ __ ] save and he hates the emperor for
that's why later on and Return of the
Jedi he whips him down the [ __ ] thing
not just cuz I got my son he's like [ __ ]
this prick and it took him a few years
so I think you could tell a pretty
compelling story get to tell would you
be able to tell Knights of the Old
Republic is he involved in and [ __ ] but
I think you get him hunting down all the
details that's that's that moves Clone
Wars before there were some [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah like there's a bunch of Jedi
out there in the world that need killing
and he's the ones that are left over
after what was it article 99
my pet no but I like the I like they
like getting used to your new reality
version of it you know taking his [ __ ]
is not all too easy order 66 that was 66
66 the [ __ ] order that ruined the
Star Wars movie like look at all these
cool Jedi's pew pew [ __ ] there's two
lights I think yes I think we could
absolutely [ __ ] him go roll on when I
was talking before about like these are
the movies you could do
I left obviously the the most important
easiest character to pull forward there
is Darth Vader once you've got a guy in
a mask
anybody's [ __ ] Darth Vader he never
gets old there never dies so you tell
Darth Vader stories I guarantee you the
audience shows up I don't think it's
like the Han Solo reaction like wow
that's not David Prowse like they're not
looking for the actor who played the
character they're looking for that
outfit and that outfit could keep
[ __ ] going and stuff like that so I
would I've never thought about that but
oh my god you can absolutely [ __ ]
just keep doing Vader movies yeah and
honestly I mean you could even bring
Darth Maul into it I mean because he got
so undersold in Episode one he got yeah
one shot by obi-wan over a flute and
they could have honestly taken him into
episode 2 you know say what spider legs
is bad
yeah the robot legs yeah yeah that'd be
a pretty good thing to see yeah
it is also you could do this sort of the
forming of the relationship between
Vader and Tarkin I think there's a world
in which you build that out right and be
like why Vader agrees to listen to
[ __ ] talkin like what is talking have
over Vader what's there with the
leverage that he has so that the most
powerful person in the universe is is
number two and also over the course of
18 years from the point he becomes Darth
Vader to the point of Star Wars like
people disregard the Jedi so much so
that you know [ __ ] generals
politicians and [ __ ] are like your
[ __ ] concern for that ancient
religion is [ __ ] stupid you know
target so you could you could see in
that 18 years the rest of the gap the
Empire particularly it was like we don't
give a [ __ ] about a guy who can like
choke people from across the room we got
the greatest weapon the world has ever
[ __ ] seen it could destroy a [ __ ]
planet
thank God is on our side yeah that's all
we're saying but at the end of the day
[ __ ] his religion and [ __ ] that's what
he believes so you could watch the
empire slowly drift away from the faith
so to speak because it is a fascist
theocracy the end of the day it's a
government run by a pope right the
[ __ ] Emperor's essentially Pope of
the dark side and [ __ ] so you can tell
that story man sorry I would tell
there's also dark side hope young Pope
the dark Pope I think there's also the
story of like there's there's a world in
which Vader is absent from the political
scene for a while like maybe he's
learning deeper version to the dark side
maybe it's more training maybe it's
whatever maybe it's meditation right
because he's constantly in [ __ ] pain
so like he tries like not a peaceful
path but like something like benefits
him because he's an agony [ __ ] so he
finds a little peace in life but then
gets dragged back just when I thought I
was out they pull me back in kind of
yeah but there's there's the beat where
he's been gone for for eight or nine
years and then returns and the Empire
had moved on without him they moved past
the idea of the Sith and religion
whatever they just became a [ __ ]
business of imperial domination I like
that but why was he away for eight years
I mean it could have been the meditation
it could've ended this animators kind of
thing and I think it could be like if
suddenly [ __ ] Vader comes back and
like what the [ __ ] we supposed to do but
this guy is forced choking [ __ ]
from across the room that's kind of
where we pick it up in Star Wars where
it's again your ancient [ __ ] war
everybody's scared of them or or they're
kind of look down the noses of the atom
or [ __ ] scared room like it seems
like the Imperials and Star Wars are
like why is this guy still here we all
got suits why is I had to get dressed
today what the [ __ ] is that kind of look
before he gets to the meeting like hey
guys anyone else bring a mask
oh shut up he's here hello lord Vader
do you need a lozenge sir
yes that was a [ __ ] fine question
that resulted in some fine thoughtful
answers give it up her lady's job you
win tickets well done talk man there's
some good goddamn discussion that creed
[ __ ] and I love it next week we're gonna
have Jill here and be like so cherries
any of this [ __ ] throughs like nope
that's right we're gonna be a little too
the person that wrote it instead um wow
that was fun that's one of the things I
love about the show yeah is nice to sit
around talk about geek [ __ ] and stuff I
like when we all get creative is fun I
never got to be in a writers room you
have I never been surrounded by a bunch
of other people being creative at once
usually I'm by myself and stuff so it's
nice when we come here and play like
that that's fun I'll go home I'll be
thinking about this all night
I'll wake my wife up at 2:00 in the
morning be like oh you know what else
Creed could do could he go to feel like
I don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about McQueen [ __ ] let's watch
it you know and that has everything to
do with the people in this room man so I
thank you all for coming out ladies and
gentlemen have you enjoyed yourselves as
Abe you a lot of that enjoyment derives
itself from the thoughts that come out
of the great mind of the man's my love
give it up for Mark Bernard
and that is fat man I'm Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I am upping our
tune in next week same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin should not forget your sign
day by Tim when you leave good night
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you